I have not spent that much time with
other Asian people who weren't my family
how much of my blood is Japanese how
much of my blood is American just
because I feel always between two
cultures hey everyone how's it going so
may is Asian Pacific American Heritage
Month and I wanted to make a video about
my culture and heritage and how I think
about that in me because I am Asian and
American I guess I actually want to make
this video like Lasher and me but my own
by way quicker than I expected and it
also did this year too which is why this
video is coming to you at the end of the
month so one of the types of videos that
was really popular last year was like
growing up Asian American my struggles
and I kind of wanted to make something
like that but slightly different and
just told from my perspective and just
my story of growing up Asian American I
also don't really like calling it my
struggles because I mean well yeah there
were some struggles at the end of the
day I wouldn't trade anything for not
being Asian I really like being Asian I
mean cuz me I am Asian isn't my boy so
yeah I feel like I had a pretty unique
experience growing up Asian American and
more specifically Japanese American so I
wanted to tell you kind of my life and
how being Asian American has affected me
and how it's been a part of my life and
how I've thought about my cultural
identity I did reference in my yappi
video that I was going to talk about
cultural identity it felt like I had a
pretty normal childhood
until maybe about high school came
around and I thought about culturally
did any issues but we'll talk about that
in another video
and now it's been a while and I feel
like I finally should give this to you
and I feel ready to talk about it okay
so let's start from the very beginning
so I was born and raised in America my
parents who are both Japanese immigrated
to the States in the early 90s to go to
grad school here my parents were the
only ones here in the US
in our family and so everybody else like
grandparents cousins aunts uncles they
all live in Japan so ever since I was
little we've gone back to Japan at least
once a year they had my brother and I
while they were still in grad school and
we lived on the East Coast for the first
like 10 years of my life I was born in
Massachusetts my brother is born New
York and then my childhood I grew up in
New York and Connecticut mostly I did
live in Japan for like two years between
the ages of like zero and like two for a
tiny little bit because my parents had a
job in Japan but it was such a long time
ago and I was so young that yeah I don't
really count them that much actually but
it did make it so that I learned
Japanese first before I learned English
which I know is very common with in
Asian American households and kids but I
learned it because I was living
literally living in Japan like I
remember my parents sent me to English
school when I was like three or four
when we first moved here most of my
elementary school days I spent in
Connecticut in some of those like really
rural places in Connecticut and I liked
it I mean when you're a kid you don't
really like notice that you're much
different from anybody else except for
maybe like the foods that you eat and
stuff but I mean I had fun
and there was nature everywhere yeah
there were some experiences that I look
back on that now I realize like yeah it
was pretty racist like for instance I
was put into English as a second
language classes from like 1st to 3rd
grade even though I was pretty confident
in my English skills at the time and I
could totally do what the kids were
doing but I got pulled aside for every
English class that I had and this lady
who is my teacher she asked me for my
name and I was like it's my you go but
she was like do you have like an easier
name to pronounce so I gave her my
middle name which is an English name but
I didn't think about it much at the time
but now I'm kind of like yeah that was
it's kind of racist like you didn't
learn my name or like there is this
other time in second grade where there
is this new kid and he was half asian
and half white and when I walked into
school not knowing the ethnicity of this
kid yet my friends were like will you go
we have found you the perfect
husband and I was like okay yeah let's
see this guy I saw him and I was like
he's not that cute but now that I look
back on it I'm like they paired me up
with him because I was the only Asian in
the class and he was Asian I mean
they're kids and like there's no about
intent obviously and they're trying to
make patterns and like there is nothing
bad that came out of it but it is kind
of a thing where it's like oh this is
the experience of living as a minority
after fifth grade we moved from
Connecticut to San Diego because my
parents got a new job and I started
fresh again in again a predominantly
white neighborhood and school in the
first couple of years of moving to San
Diego is pretty turbulent because sixth
grade is at a time where you just like
start cliques and you also start
noticing other people and there's
popularity and there's groups and weird
social things that are happened because
of hormones and stuff so the first
couple of years I will say were really
rough in making friends and then I think
I remember in eighth grade was the first
time that I had like a mostly Asian
friend group which was super novel to me
cuz I was like I have not spent that
much time with other Asian people who
weren't my family and I felt really
comfortable in that space cuz well we
were all very different kinds of Asian
almost like hey like no one's gonna make
fun of me for the bento that I bring to
school which yes
sidenote I feel really bad about this
but my mom used to make me delicious
bentos to bring to school and so many
kids would ask so many questions about
what the food is again like that's not a
bad thing like they're genuinely curious
but sometimes I would get opinions about
my food or I would get like oh that's
gross kind of complaints and stuff and
so I asked my mom to stop making me
bento and give me Lunchables and
sometimes I would like hide and eat my
bento which is such a shame because the
moms bentos are really good and she also
put a lot of heart into that so yeah I'm
sorry mom so then I went into high
school and I was kind of this like
pretty stereotypically Asian kid because
my high school joined a lot of other
middle schools there was a lot more
Asian people I was good at math
because I had a lot of good math
teachers and also because my dad tutored
me in math cuz he used to be a math
teacher I took a lot of AP classes
actually didn't even know what they were
in my freshman year because no one told
me about them so I feel like in some
ways I learned how to be Asian through
some of my friends who didn't know a
little bit more or whose parents told
them like how to do stuff and what to do
to go to college because I think maybe
the thing that my parents told me was
just like go to college and get a good
education but they have like how to get
through an American school system and
how to do that was something that they
didn't know so kind of to figure it out
myself but luckily I had other friends
and school counselors and teachers and
stuff who I didn't really talk to you
because I was like I can't really trust
you for some reason but high school
comes with high school puberty issue
things of existentialism and questions
about you and yourself and this is
really when the cultural identity stuff
hit I mean when I was little I did ask
my parents I was like in my Japanese or
American and I distinctly remember
asking my dad I was like how much of my
blood is Japanese and how much of my
blood is American and he was like you're
fully Japanese but you're also American
I was like
but that makes no sense so in high
school without any of those questions
answered I really started like thinking
I'm like okay like really who the heck
am i I also just gotten a lot more like
fights with my parents and I just
noticed that their expectations of me
was really different from what my
friends expectations from their parents
were and stuff and I remember them being
very like kind of specific to Japanese
culture one thing that my parents always
told me was like we expect you to grow
up as a Japanese woman living in America
and I was like what tax does that even
mean and I mean sometimes it was small
stuff like don't forget to always bring
a gift to whoever's house you're going
to or always bring your brother to your
house or I mean the big one was that I
had to do Japanese school on Saturdays
like one of my two days off from high
school and learn Japanese so I think I
was just really frustrated by like my
parents expectations like what I thought
my expectations were as an Asian person
living in America at that time but also
my school's expectations my friends
expectations and I didn't even know what
like my own expectations were the
question that I just really didn't know
how to answer was in my Japanese or in
my American or my Japanese American none
of those labels ever seemed to fit me
because I'm not just Japanese I'm also
not just American and Japanese American
to me seemed like it described a
completely different generation of
people that I didn't really identify
with japanese-american described to me
the descendants of a generation of
Japanese people who immigrated to the
u.s. in the early 1900s and lived
through World War two and the
concentration camps and now are living
in a very different state of Japanese
American myths and I didn't identify
with that because I still had family
living in Japan I try to stay as
connected as I could to Japan and its
culture and what's going on in luckily
at the time too I was friends with a lot
of asian-americans in my
and we were definitely minority but we
like stuck together and I think that
really helped me through it all because
well I'm not actually sure if they had
some of the same questions they also
were living this like minority
experience in the same town at the same
school and it at least gave me kind of
just a sense of belonging that like yes
I do have a place here and I belong here
and I have friends who care about me it
was also around that time that YouTube
became a thing and tons of Asian
American youtubers started flooding the
platform and seeing them be them online
was like revolutionary to me I just
remember following kina grannis she's
half Japanese and half white and she was
just like doing her from the outside it
didn't seem like she was plagued by the
same sort of debate inside her had of
like if she Japanese or American or what
she probably was in her head but like I
was like oh she is just doing her and
she's living her life it was the first
time I'd it's kind of like you know I
don't need to identify into any of these
three labels to define what my cultural
identity is yet I'm just gonna figure it
out but myself like my parents obviously
have a very different identity for me my
brother was three years younger and was
kind of working through it on his own
that I knew that I needed to just like
make sure that no matter what I do I
felt very true to me and I felt myself
the whole time
as long as my you go fit the label of
who I was then I was okay with it I mean
I make it sound easy and stuff but it
was pretty hard cuz like at the time and
was like watching so much Japanese
television and listening to so much
j-pop cuz I was like I need stay
connected to my Japanese roots but I
mean it was the way that I like helped
my way through myself like I had a
journal where I wrote about all this and
it's all very existential it's very
teenager II but it was the way that I
processed like figuring out who the heck
I was anyways I graduated high school
and I went on to college to UCSD which
if you don't know is a very Asian school
I was feeling the sense of like oh like
I'm not I'm not nearly as Asian as these
other people and also a lot of these
folks were not Japanese because
I mean when you talk about Asian
representation like there's actually not
that many Japanese people around I think
but I still kind of went through this
like I'm just gonna do me also computer
science was really demanding and hard so
it kind of didn't have time to think
about it but I did join the Japanese
Student Association as a way to just
like get to know other Japanese people
and kind of kept exploring a little bit
like Who am I and what does this mean
and where do I find my place in the
world although I will say in college
that I started feeling this pressure of
like needing to be og and have ties to
the motherland and feel authentic and
get like know what's going on in Japan
which I don't know it's it's like this
underlying pressure that I feel like is
still going on a little bit anyways it
was around this time that I started to
feel a little bit of like pressure to
stay connected to Japan and what's going
on because I wanted to make sure to like
stay true to my Japanese heritage I
guess so then I graduated and I started
working and I feel like when you're
working you have a little bit more
agency over who you are and what you
identify as and I make decisions so I
was kind of really leaning into this
like I'm gonna do me and I'm gonna
figure out what that means also starting
to live by yourself means like hey like
what are you gonna cook for yourself
like is it gonna be mostly Japanese food
how does eating Japanese food make you
feel versus other kinds of food and so I
was exploring this identity in kind of a
different way of just living through
life and just feeling it out a little
bit in this new environment called
adulthood and I think I'm still kind of
on that journey of just like figuring
out what my cultural identity is but I
think my kind of rule of just like hey
you just do you and see how different
things feel is still my policy so do I
identify as Asian American yeah I would
say so
do I identify as Japanese no American no
Japanese American yeah no not that
either actually
I feel like recently I've just started
labeling myself as like Japanese and
American just because I feel always
between two cultures that pressure of
needing to stay og and stuff of like
being connect
to the motherland still exists but also
I'm more willing to let it go because
it's in place of making me feel more
like me and culture is just one aspect
of my personality and Who I am
there's lots of other dimensions that
still need to be explored and sometimes
are more important to me at different
times so growing up I will say was a
little hard because it felt pretty
alienating but at the time I didn't
really notice how being
japanese-american was affecting my life
and now it's become a lot more apparent
and I actually really embrace that side
of me and nowadays I'm really happy when
I can share my culture with other people
who are or are not Japanese I think I
have a maybe unique perspective on Japan
and America that maybe I only share but
with myself and people like me but I
like it and I think it really shapes Who
I am in my worldview and yeah that's at
the end of the sentence I'm a huge fan
of all the conversations that are going
around about what it means to be
asian-american so I'm happy to throw my
story in the mix because I don't think
there's not many like japanese-american
people in there so I hope you enjoyed
this video if you have any questions for
me for anything specific I talked about
in this video or anything else that you
want to ask me about my cultural
heritage then leave a comment down below
I know y'all really like my yappy video
and I'm happy to talk more about this
I'm really passionate about this stuff
and I'm happy to be a part of the
conversation alright that's it for today
thank you so much for watching I hope
you liked this video don't forget to hit
the like button and also subscribe I
don't get paid for either of those
things but it gives me a sense of what
you like and how many people are
interested in listening to my story so
please do those things I hope you have a
great day wherever you are gonna say bye
Wow oh hi Kona yes yes boo boo thank you
what job you want me to give you pets
what what is it what do you want do you
want Pat's you know what you want you
want to be on my YouTube video are you
go boy yes you are